one of our deepest longings is for
safety we search for it through money
exercise a good diet a sound reputation
insurance seatbelts love and yet we
remain always horribly vulnerable a tiny
blood clot and we're gone a small slip
and our reputations destroyed a moment
of inattention on the road and we're
dead a few temptations and relationships
shatter we remain subject to a constant
array of random accidents meteorites far
above and malignant cells deep within we
don't have enough information to make
wise choices over a lifetime we can hold
back the chaos for a while but entropy
erosion and destruction will win out in
the end
the calm of a sunny morning the money
you're saving the house you feel you own
the friendships you lay claim to the
relationship you think is beyond
question
none of these promise lasting safety we
are all always desperately vulnerable
our grasp on life therefore needs to be
loosed grateful and ready for the worst
our imaginations no strangers to the
full range of scenarios we should also
have a small dark space in our minds
where we acknowledged just how perilous
everything we are and do really is we
should in this space be solemn and
awestruck by the dangers were up against
and when we can manage it before the
small everyday apocalypse is that do all
of us in eventually we should struggle
to be kind and cheerful
if you like our films take a look at our
shop the School of Life comm forward
slash shop you'll find lots of
thoughtful books games stationery and
more
you